today on cloud storage bytes we're gonna
go where a lot of web devs would rather
not go we're talking about cores and
we're gonna do it twice in true storage
bytes fashion I'll be with you every
step of the way
so keep calm and stay tuned for part one
of our cours
adventure
contrary to what other web devs might
tell you Korres is a security feature of
browsers and not just a frustration
dream come to life first I'll give an
overview of what Korres is then I'll
address how to implement Korres for
Google Cloud storage objects let's get
to the basics of understanding Korres
first of all Korres is short for
cross-origin resource sharing to
understand what this means it really
helps to first understand same-origin
resource sharing the same origin policy
is a security policy enforced on web
browsers to prevent interactions between
resources from different origins like
domains I like to think of it as
preventing a bait-and-switch if I go to
a web site say cat pics I expect to
interact with resources of cat pics but
what if cat pics instead of showing
photos of adorable cats downloaded
malicious software from some other web
site the same origin policy looks at the
calls that are coming from a website and
ensures they come from you guessed it
the same origin so the same origin
policy is a good thing
it protects users however it can also
prevent legitimate interactions between
known origins for example a script on a
page hosted on App Engine at example
appspot.com might need to use resources
stored in a cloud storage bucket at
example storage google api is calm these
are two different origins from the
perspective of the browser thinks of
that trusty same origin policy the
browser won't allow a script from
example appspot.com to fetch resources
from example storage google api is calm
you've probably experienced this as a
cores error admittedly not ideal but
take a deep breath what does this mean
and how do we fix it the cross-origin
resource sharing spec also known as
cores was developed by the World Wide
Web Consortium to get around
limitations of same-origin policy cloud
storage support scores by allowing you
to configure your buckets to support it
so in our example case you can configure
the example storage Google API is comm
bucket so that a browser can share its
resources with the scripts from example
appspot.com
and there you go no more cores error now
that you know a bit more about cores
you're ready to get configuring there's
plenty more to come about resource
sharing but we're saving that for next
week if you want to know more about
cloud storage and cores and don't want
to wait for part two check out the links
in the description don't forget to
subscribe give us a like and tell us
what you want to learn about cloud
storage thanks for joining us for this
quick byte of cloud storage see you next
time
[Music]